a different thing but that's okay too
[Music]
hey guys i'm vaughn i'm a tasty producer
here at tasty
in new york city and i
love pizza
i almost got hit by a car i think i can
make a homemade pizza that rivals new
york's best pizza and america's most
popular pizza so i'm going to invite
some friends over they're going to try
all three and they're going to tell me
which one they like best all right guys
let's go make some pizza
[Music]
[Applause]
so listen the best part of a pizza is
it's crust right bad crust bad pizza i
tested a bunch of recipes and this is by
far my favorite because it is so
simple
and it yields a lot of dough i mean
after all i am throwing a pizza party
you just have to whisk the dry
ingredients together like this but it is
so easy i'm going to make a little divot
in the center it'll start to come
together kind of slowly at first but
then you'll really start to see your
dough form now another great thing about
this dough is that there's no kneading
required all i'm going to do is make
sure all those ingredients are evenly
incorporated all you need to worry about
is making sure everything is combined
and washing your hands the dough should
feel really springy once you push in it
should come back to place i'm going to
cover this and i'm going to leave it out
overnight until it's doubled in size
like i said there's a lot of good
recipes out there that don't call for
this long of a proof but this was the
easiest for me because it was so simple
if i'm feeding a crowd i want to make
everything as easy on myself as possible
pizza really is a delicate balance
you've got the the crust the backbone
you've got the cheese and the toppings
to kind of determine what it is but
without the sauce you don't have
anything to balance everything
out i knew i was getting something which
was garlic and if i didn't put garlic in
this recipe i think that every nona
below 14th street would have my head
just gonna give it a taste
oh
[Music]
that's good
so that was easy i'm just gonna jar it
pretty airtight and i'm gonna let those
flavors hang out until i'm ready to make
my pizza
i have my beautiful dough here you can
see how porous
and airy that's going to be kind of
feels like a demogorgon that air is
going to yield a really light
yet crisp crust i'm going to go quickly
and carefully trying to not overwork the
dough here this recipe has yielded me
six
perfect
dough rounds for 10 inch pizzas which is
going to be amazing for my party
transfer them to a floured baking sheet
where we're going to cover them with a
damp towel
[Music]
they're perfect now the fun part begins
tossing it really is the best way to get
a thin crust to do it you kind of have a
window pane look there
[Music]
two of the most important things i
learned about baking pizza is that you
need to preheat a really hot oven with a
pizza stone in it and you need to well
flour your pizza peel i chose gruyere
and smoked mozzarella for my pizza
because i think they work really well
together
and i want all the cheese
[Music]
let's put this in the oven because of
the cornmeal the dough slides right off
now if you don't have a pizza stone do
not worry because another great way to
make awesome pizza is with a cast iron
skillet
the best thing about homemade pizza is
my pizza it's not yours you can do
whatever you want to it with some fresh
basil and some parmigiano reggiano
forget about it
now it's time to see how they stack up i
think we're ready to go up against new
york pizza and classic delivery pizza
so we have our three slices of pizza
here
now
let's break it down
in terms of price you can't be the two
dollar new york slice of pizza however
the only things i really had to buy for
my pizza were the toppings that being
said if you're gonna make your own pizza
you might as well ball out with what you
put on it in terms of time that's where
the homemade's lagging a little bit i
did have to let my dough rest overnight
but other than that it really only took
about 15 minutes to mix the dough and
the sauce and once everything was ready
it baked in about nine minutes arguably
the most important part of any pizza the
crust
new york pizza is great you gotta eat it
right away or else it kind of loses its
charm delivery pizza we all know what
that's like
my pizza is
cracker thin until you get to the crust
where it's nice and charred and it's
pretty fluffy at the edge too in terms
of experience
that's where mine takes the cake for
sure i mean you really cannot beat
having a pizza party with all your
friends
they went wild with toppings and bases
and shapes and sizes it was really
really fun we had a great night and it
was cool to see what everybody came up
with 10 out of 10
would recommend
taste is the biggest thing let's see
what my friends have to say
i'm going to say my favorite was the
second one it was nostalgia all over the
place definitely the third
the third pizza was probably the best my
favorite pizza i think was number one
number three mandy what was your
favorite
[Music]
number three
i say that they're all amazing for
whatever
mood you're in you've got to get a quick
two dollar slice you gotta order pizza
because you can't get out of bed or you
want to have a fun pizza party either
way you go you can't go wrong i mean
pizza is bae but i cannot remember the
last time i consumed something green
honestly
i was like get me a salad
right now
[Music]
you